herkeze
[Müzik]
Merhaba arkadaşlar
herkeze önceki konuşmayı arkadaşlar da
dinledim
Huyum kurusun Maalesef şimdi ben
hangi etkinlik olursa olsun sporda olsun
öyle konuşmaları dostun mu Hep öpüyorum
bu mu spreyi kıskandığım açıkçası
Maşallah e sabahlayacağım özel
arkadaşlar ilk başta yetişiyorum
tutmasın bakıyorsunuz
bu ve plana gibi
anlatmak başıma söyleşme
ve Hatta iki anlamadım ben
var
Bir tane de
O
ne o
ve askeri Okul dışında Askeri okulda o
zaman çalışmaya başladık Yani ilk orta
ve liseyi ettim ben işte çalışmalarını
sevdim
Bu Nasıl olduysa bugün
o tarihlerde çalışma TL'lik Çünkü öpmen
o günleri kapattıracak sözlü notu
verecek
bu
çalışma ihtiyacı duyduk çalıştık hazır
hissediyorum kendimi Sözde Esra bana
gitmedi Bu heyecan yine beni yatırmadı
kalkıyorum güzel hızlı atlatıyorum böyle
o Heyecanın eşliğinde
uçmaktır
bugün
yaptı orada Kemal Sunal'ı dedik pot
kırdık bütün sınıfa maalesef böyle bir
şekilde izle olmuştur
Bu şekilde bir konuşma etkinliği
Evet Ee
Bir Demet Akalın şu an bakın mutlu
bakarmısın İstanbul'da
O hep ile başlayan şifresi 60
Üniversitesi'nde bir etkinlik daha dedik
bu şekilde o benim seninle konuşuyorum
atılan Üniversitesi diyeceğim Ben Efe
nasıl çıktı Bakalım burada ne yaptım
daha çok
bile ilgili pat kırıyorum bu Mimar
geçtikçe Çelik telleri karıştırıyorum
1900'lü yıllarla 2000'li yıllarla ifade
etti
1998 22018 dediğim çok oluyor
çok güzel oldu karşı karşıya kalırsak
beni Amerika karışacağız a inanıyorum
Evet
staj başarısıyla ilgili buraya gelecek
şu taş başarımızı sizlere anlatmaya
çalışacağız
Bunlar tabii
da atmadın değil mi o zamanlarda ilgili
de örnekler vermek zorunda kalacağım
Sen benim hayatıma girdi Ben
ve
1980'li yılların 86 yıllık arkadaşlar
tekvando sporuna başladım O zaman biraz
kuşağı
o yumuşak bir sporcuyum ya da bir aylık
bir sporcu arkadaş O da biraz Paşa
bu
Millette hocamızın odasında gördüm bunu
kıskandım ya bu adam nasıl olur da
hocamızın odasına gelir Biz giremiyoruz
bir ayda vereceğimiz zaman geliyoruz o
hesabı fişte ayran ödeyeceğim zaman
o odada gördüm
yok abla derken nasip yaklaştığımda fark
ettim hocaya satranç oynuyor
de hiç bilmediğim bir
a Brain satranç
Bu etken Arkadaşlar bunu öğretim değil
mi öğren bir neydi taşların hareketi at
böyle gider fil böyle gider yapıyorum Ve
bu şekilde gider bildiğimiz buydu sonra
Hocama
Tabii dedim Hocam ben de saklanmış
Biliyorum öyle mi Gel bakalım
bu müdüriyete girdik bu onu yaşadık
mutluyuz zor alıyoruz hocamızın odasına
girmek bizim için bir başarı
O da hocam da tabi basit bir insan değil
Türkiye Tekvando tarihinde ilk Avrupa
şampiyonu çeşit kendisi ilk altın
madalya almış Avrupa şampiyonu
bıraktırdı kendisi
de oturduk
bu arkadaş dört tane de Oyun bitti o
camın fazlasını karşına ben kıpkırmızı
kaldım şok olması denilen şeyi
bilmiyorum videoyu
tabi Ondan sonra sataş benden uzaklaştı
sadece taşların hareketi aklımda
O çok nadir oynamıştı bu piyonları
rastgele veriyorum ve onlar bana sıkıntı
oluyor diğer taşları rahat rahat hareket
ettirmek için bana bir sıkıntı atfil
oynatamıyorum zaten
ve hemen piyano veriyordu
da o sıralar
Tabii şunu da duydum dediler ki satrancı
Arabistan'da develeriyle üstünde
oynuyorlarmış
kendi kendime düşünüyorum ya de ve
dışında insan zor durup mi satranç
takımı nasıl durur ve
bu işte
25 Eylül'de
bu Van ili Gevaş İlçesi'nde göre yaptım
sıralarda
ve Terörle mücadelede
her babasının
o dudaklarını da kullanılmaması infilak
etmesi sonucu maalesef yaralandık uzun
yıllar tedavi gördük ve Ankara'da bir
kentte
çok küçük şahlı kuvvetlerin bu
inşa etmiş olduğu ele Vakfı'nın
aracılığıyla
sıralı Kuvvetleri ve Rehabilitasyon ve
Bakım Merkezi Başkanlığı açıldı
ve o da
benim gibi Gazi arkadaşları rahatsız
ediyorlar
gittik baktık
ve görme engelliler için herhangi bir
etkinlik herhangi bir yaptı edecektir
bir kaynak mevcut değil Bu bir Gazi
arkadaşlar araştırma yaptık ve bu işin
işin uzmanı kimdir bu renge sahip olan
dernekler Altı Nokta ile irtibata geçtik
Aslan eğitimi bilgisayar eğitimi Prime
alfabe Eğitimi ve sportif faaliyetlerin
mevcut olduğunu öğrendi
sağolsunlar komutanlarımız da işlerimize
Paşa işlerine falan bunları sık sık
ziyaret ederlerdi halimizi hatırımızı
sorular bir ricada bulunduk bir görme
engelli içinde kuşlar açıldı
ama nedir
bu bilgisayar on parmak eğitim bu
İbrahim alfabe yine on parmak sağlam
Olması lazım Ben de sağlam bir parmak
da
baston bilgi denedim sağa-sola salınımı
elimden fırsatı dedi ya
biz bol bol sporu var arkadaşlar
ve o da [ __ ] Yani top Bedel karşılığı
yuvarlanıyor kaleler var uçak kişide
değil var o sese göre topuklu tanıyorsun
üzere takım halinde Bu da bana göre
değil Çünkü işitme engelliyim demedim
topun nereden geldiğini bilmiyordum
Şu bilgisayar sağlam halindeki mesela
hiç anlam veremediğim 5 rakamını
üstündeki Oo nokta
ev klavyede ABK üzerinde şimdi klavyede
Tabii FB J harfleri üzerinde
kabakların nokta dedim ya Allah Allah
yolunda fabrika sürekli böyle mi çıkar
bu ve görme engeli şimdi bir Kılavuz
Bir tuşla almış onlar Onu öğrendik o
zaman
bu
bilgisayar Peki nasıl olacak şimdi
Bilgisayar Paşa işleri benim kullanmamı
çok istiyorlar Dış Dünya ile bağlantımı
çok güzel bir şekilde sağlayacak bir
tanem
arkadaşlarımı diğer görme engelli Gazi
arkadaşlar parmakları sağlam ve kursa
oturduk öğretmen anlatıyor arkadaşlara
bana geldi
a işte İbrahim Bey ben size nasıl
yardımcı olayım bilemiyorum dedi
Hoca'yı dinlemedim menüsünde elimi
gezdirdim Çünkü mesela jandarmaya ifade
alıyor da TL kullandığımız için ilk
atıklar diyebiliyoruz
benden önce işte bu sefer abimizin
yaptığı konuşma
o orada
çözüm üretme
bu öyle bir şey değil zaten
Bu nasıl öğrenebilirim klavyeyi kendi
kendime
ve Space tuşu yani boşluk alalım tuşu
yanında defa çıtır asker arkadaşım vardı
süper isim sol köşesinden yukarı çıktım
Bugün hangi harf diğer Tamam onun yanı
sol tarafı ilk size Q klavye için
konuşuyorum Bunu bütün Harflerin yerini
ezberledim be ve fb-bjk ha kendisindeki
noktaları da şu sağ işaret parmağım
zaten bir orada doku hissi var onunla da
Park edebiliyorum
Yani uzun dikdörtgen dediğimiz sana göre
ki bölüme ezberledim Sağ taraf işte yön
tuşları Yukarıdaki tuşlar derken
numaraları de ezberledik hepsine be
Allah'a şükür Bir Tek parmakla Evet şu
an bilgisayarda kullanıyorum
internete giriş yapabiliyorum
arkadaşlarla görüşüyorum ki bunda ile de
yine anlatacağım
bu
satranç
eğitimi de veriliyor kapatma tahta var
arkadaşlar siyah kareler için düz bir
şekilde
bu önemli bir şey olduğunu bilmiyordum
Allah Allah ya
o bana bakar edemedim
Tamam hiç
beyaz karelerde çukur şeklinde ve bu
karelerin içinde de yuvalar var taşların
altında de peşinde mi yapılmış o
yuvaları oturuyorlar
5 Gazi arkadaşız onlar hepsini elleri
sağlığım sadece engel gözlerinde oturduk
öğretmen
şimdi anlatıyor anlatırken
bu taşları şöyle diye Renault tavşan
dediğimiz arkadaşlar Satrançta notasyon
vardır
brow notasyona göre biz taşlara görme
diyoruz
var ama şimdi Malum hepiniz Mahmut Aka
görmüştür satranç tahtasını ve taşlarını
2016'da yazın 16 siyah taşırlar toplam
32-64 kalem üstünde 32 taş mevcut
taşın diline yuvadan çıkartıp bir başka
boya götürmekten misin
imkansız bir halde yapamıyorum Yani bir
ile kontrol edeceksin diğeri de
götürecek taşı bulmak lazım bu maalesef
kendimi kontrol edemedim bir öfke
başarısızlığın
işimiz olmuş oldu bir öfke taşı fırlatıp
attım şöyle elimde
öğretmen yani kursu bize veren öğretmen
ne oldu İbrahim hocam yapamıyorum
olmuyor dedim
işte İnsanı etkileyen bir durum oldu
beni orada hocamın Hani bir başkası
söylese hiç inanmayacaksınız bu
sözlerdeki basit gelecek Demek ki işin
uzmanları o sesi duyunca
o dedi ki göreceksin Bunlar içinde en
iyisi alacaksın
Evet arkadaşlar şimdi bunu söyledim ya
Nasıl olabilirdi bu adamlar belediye
kullanıyor Tatlı Geceler mecbur şey
yapamıyorum anlatıyor öğretmen olsa da
ben de elim Arkadaşlar bu şekilde
bağlamışım arkaya sanmışım tam orayı
terk edip gitmedik masayı odayı terk
edip gitmedik masada oturuyorum
arkadaşlara soru yöneltti Şah dedi kendi
Kalesi dahil
bu Şah Çelik arası dahil
kaç kare gider
arkadaşlar parmaklarıyla hesaplarken
daha ben hemen zihinden
karşıda bir satranç tahtası oluşturdum
bir pano
hop arada sanki E4 karşındaki
şahıs hesapladım kaç kere gider hızlı
bir şekilde dokuz kare dedi
var yani ben o ana kadar de dahil
değildim işte orada da arkadaşlar
Devenin üstünde Arapların nasıl satranç
oynadığımda Öğrenmiş oldum yani körleme
satrak zihinden satranç oyunu
Ne
gördün mü dedi hoca bu başarıdan işte
ve bu işte bu sözsüz beni
satranca daha yakın kaldı
bırakmadım
dersler hep zihinden dinledim arkadaşlar
ellerini kullanacağım Ben hep zihinden
tahta karşımda hamleler böyle zihinden
kontrol ediyorum derken
tabi ilk kursumuzda öğretmen Sadece
taşları hareketini ve tahtadan nasıl
geldiğini anlatıyor
kursumuzu çay kadar sürdü
gitti evde bilgisayarda satranç
oynuyorum sürekli yeniliyorum
bilgisayara karşı oynuyorum ve
2009 yılında Maraş'ta bir görme
engelliler Türkiye şampiyonası yapılacak
davet edildim Ya ben ne yapabiliriz ne
edebiliriz bir şey bilmiyorum ki derken
kasko dünya şampiyonu bunun bilgisayara
karşı oynamış oldu
partiler mevcut altı parti 6 rahatlık
Evet
arkadaşlar
bir düşünün bir rahatla diğeri Melih
anne yapılmış 50 Beyaz'ın 50
siyahısı Biz bunu kısa indirelim
ortalama altı parti için
sabah kırk ham eden olduğunuz işinin
o 200
kaçar mı yapıyor bu
afrikası çarparsak 240 ne yapıyor Değil
mi
Evet Ee 246
Evet
Ee mi toplasak 24 180 toplamda çıkıyor
beyaz ve siyahın Kırk Haramilerin olduğu
için altı Fatih'in hamlesini kafamda
ezberledim
Bu bir Fatih işte birinci Ahmed en son
hamle kadar Hepsini ezberledim o şekilde
gittim yani kaç para oynamış
sabah doğru oynamıştır ama hemen
mantıklı bilmiyorum ne için aramış
Bilmiyorum
hiçbir eğitim almadım sadece bilgisayara
karşı oynadım eğitimle gittim
Oturma da dik katıldığı turnuva ilk ona
girdim dokuzuncu oldu
ama orada duyduğumuz bir şey oldu
bu aynı zamanda milli takım çantaları
ve verimli ve milli takım sporcusu o
zaman çıkacağım belli değil değil mi
Onlara da işte Fransız da böyle yaptın
Şu hata yaptım yok İngiliz açısında şu
oldu Yok siz ya da bu oldu Allah Allah
İngilizce Fransızca İtalyanca ve bunları
bilmiyorum meğer onun adı açılış isimler
iyiymiş
bu satrancı ustalarıyla
tanıştım dedim ben satrancı ile etmem
lazım o zaman hiçbir şey bilmiyorum
Sadece hareketlerini biliyorum taşların
Grand Master satrançta en yüksek
seviyede olan isimler ünvanlar buna bir
de Master in thermaster Grand Master bu
şekilde gider arkadaşla
önce İnter masterla tanıştım
Türkmenistan milli takım sporcusu bizim
Adana'ya Bir turnuvaya gelmişler bu
ama
senden rica ettim yani bir bahane
evimize davet ettik
bir şeyler öğrenebilir miyim acaba diye
ve bunların hepsinden çıkmışlar
gelmişler
söylemem hesaptan soyunuyor Bu arkadaşın
thermaster
o çok basit bir şekilde tabi benim yendi
Sen bana de ki İbrahim abi dedi açılışta
Eksik Ne yapacağız Keşke ben sen de
olsaydın sana bir şeyler ödedik sorun
değil hocam dedim ben gelirim arkadaşlar
Bunu öğrenmek için sağolsun eşim de
fedakarlık yaptı
Ben de aracımızda git gel o yolu kat
ettik Yani bir şeyler öğrenmek istiyorum
çünkü satranç öğrenmek istiyorum eğitimi
çok pahalı bir spor
saptaki gittim Ondan bir şeyler öğrendim
derken bırakmasıyla tanıştık Ondan bir
şeyler öğrendik satrancın mantığını
anlamaya başladım
Eyvah bir dakika burada Çabuk geçiyormuş
zaman
eğitim aldık
2013 yılında bu
benimse tekvandodaki başlamak dediğim
şehir Satrançta masif oldu 2013 yılında
Türkiye şampiyon oldu milli takımı
temsil ettim o milli takımı formasını
giymek bu duyguyu yaşamak beni inanın
çok mutlu etti ama zaman Bakın bu kadar
çabuk geçeceğim Hiç tahmin etmedim ben
dinleyici var olurken dinlediğimde 18
dakikada Ben de konuşabilirim diyordum
ama bu maalesef hiç yetmiyormuş burada
Daha konuşacak çok sevdiğim vardı
herhalde olmayacak yetmeyecek pek Ama
hayatın bir satranç olduğunu ben
satrancın mantığını anlayamadım
arkadaşlar
ben Bunu bilmenizi istiyorum Hayat bir
satranç tır
abone ol